ce cinéma de toronto à arborer les
couleurs de la matrice pour la grande
première du nouveau film de la série il
y avait un air de déjà vu pour keanu
reeves mais depuis
le premier film de la série la matrice a
vu le jour il ya plus de vingt ans il
s'agissait d'une véritable révolution
cinématographique
parce qu'on n'avait jamais vu de tels
effets spéciaux au ralenti et des
combats en apesanteur ou des caméras
tourner autour des acteurs pour des gens
de ma génération en fait ça nous a
beaucoup beaucoup influencé impressionné
que moi en fait ça vous coups ç'a été un
événement qui m'a orienté dans ma
carrière puis amenés à l'est dans l'est
les effets numériques
la matrice a remporté quatre oscars dont
celui du meilleur d'effets spéciaux mais
la matrice a aussi marqué les esprits
avec son histoire d'un monde où les
machines contrôle virtuellement l'esprit
les humains la matrice on pourrait aussi
réactualise de grande tradition
philosophique occidentale d'une part
justement l'idée que ce que nous
percevons n'est pas nécessairement vrai
donc toute une tradition philosophique
qui vient avec ça et ensuite celle du
libre arbitre
donc on peut comprendre que la matrice à
cette idée là de descartes dans les
méditations métaphysiques sur le dé du
mauvais génie donc il est temps qu'ils
créent un monde dans lequel on évolue
qui n'est pas vrai dans la matrice le
héros doit choisir entre la pilule bleue
et la pilule rouge la pilule bleue et
celle du déni de la réalité et la pilule
rouge et celle de la volonté d'apprendre
la vérité que l'humain est l'esclave de
la machine cette image a été maintes
fois récupérer parfois à tort et à
travers
la matrice ouvert la porte à une espèce
de passer un peu simpliste un certain
niveau aussi où c'est facile de dire on
est toutes plongé dans une machine c'est
pas grave
ou n'y a rien qui existe c'est pas vrai
où il n'y a pas de conséquences qu'est
ce qu'on fait si facile de faire des
affirmations comme ça le premier film la
matrice est sorti en 1999 soit cinq ans
avant la création de la bêta tapson
numérique ps book j'ai fait des rêves
qui n'étaient pas que des rêves en 2021
la matrice à quelque chose de bien
réelles et ils seront nombreux à voir la
suite baptisée la matrice résurrection
si tu veux revoir qu'il était
ici depuis mai radio-canada maurienne
[Musique]